All right,
let's get started. My name's John Rogers.
I'm a, uh, client partner for Pearson,
and I just have the pleasure
to manage both AWS and the
ServiceNow relationship,
um.
Let's see, I guess after about 6 months of
research,
we concluded, uh, about midway
through this year
and we, uh, developed a report. It's
a workforce skills forecast
report collaboratively with ServiceNow.
Um, what we did in this report is
we looked, use machine learning, we use
economic analysis, we use predictive
analytics,
and we're able to evaluate
not only market shifts from a labor perspective
but also how agentic AI
and related technologies
uh impact a role, so
out of the task level, how they impact
an industry, how they impact a country,
and roll that up to macroeconomics as well,
right? So it's a really fascinating report.
So I'd like to bring, um,
uh, introduce my two colleagues here next to
me. So one is Ian Gott. He's
a senior director for sales
for, um, ServiceNow in
AI
data and analytics, and also Ray
Murray for Pearson. Hello everyone, and he's our
CRO and an SVP at Pearson.
And what we like to. Us today is dive
into how these technologies
are going to really redefine the world of
work,
um, how that we can
collaborate with AI as individuals,
right? And also just
starting to reimagine, I think
organizations are going to have to start reimagining how
AI impacts and how we work together
collaboratively.
So with that I'm going to kick it off.
I'll start with Ray.
Um,
what are kind of the key trends that you saw in
the research that would, that triggered
a reaction from you?
Yeah, well, thank you, um, thanks,
JR. First of all, I'll just start off by saying
it's wonderful to be here uh
at AWS Reinvent,
um, and to have this opportunity
to talk about powering the future of work.
I find it a little ironic, I have to say
that, uh,
we're sitting here in front of people that essentially
build and ship,
uh, the tools of how uh we're gonna
power the future of work and you and I are.
Uh, more on the theory side
of things, uh, but it's wonderful to
be here. And I also like a huge shout out
to, um, Ion from, uh,
ServiceNow, an organization that does so
much, uh, to bring products and services,
uh, that, uh, reshape the way we do work,
uh, and, and make our daily
lives very rewarding.
So essentially the res the headline of
the research is.
Agentic AI is not an
IT upgrade, it's a massive,
massive seismic shift
to every economy worldwide like we've
never seen.
And it will disrupt every
industry, um,
um, and, but not necessarily in a straight line
uh uh way.
By 2030, uh, we're estimating
that about 8
million people, the survey, uh, the, the
research showed that in America alone, 8 million
people's roles will get disrupted.
Uh, and that will get that disruption's
gonna happen,
um, at the skills level. It's
going to happen, um, you know,
by augmenting those skills and by redefining
roles, and the paradox
is that AI is disrupting
at a very fast pace,
um.
But the needs for skills are
actually uh going higher
at even a, a faster, a
faster pace. And in the, and if you, when you
look at the, the research in 8 of the 10
countries,
um, that we researched, there will be
more work,
uh, than workers to actually do the work
itself. Um, and that's great news,
that's great news for all of us, it's great news,
um, for all, uh, all
the attendees at, at, at Reinvent
because it really is job security.
Um, and so really the takeaway
at a macro level is that AI is
not reducing,
uh, demand for tech,
uh, talent itself, it's actually fueling
it moving forward.
Yeah, thanks, Ray. And Ian, would you,
can you, so that's a great macro macroeconomic
brush.
Can you take us in from an industry view that you're
seeing? Yeah, absolutely. So we,
we saw that with financial services,
um, you're going to see maybe a higher impact in
that type of industry. For example,
in Japan,
you know, as much as 15% of
that workforce impacted
in that particular industry and maybe some similar
trends
in the US
as well as other parts of the world. As
we get into other industries like retail
as well, we're going to see kind of a disproportionate
impact in in in countries like India and the
UK. When it comes to
things like inventory management,
customer service,
you're already seeing some of that, you know, probably as
an online shopper in your experience
in terms of how AI is recommending
products or how you're checking out,
and then other areas too like professional
services, technology,
other industry segments will be
impacted, but it's more. About the augmentation of
how AI will help further enhance
those jobs and roles.
And then lastly,
when speaking of roles and knowledge workers in
Singapore, we found
those knowledge workers are quite advanced,
so they're taking AI and making it
part of their day to day job and really
accelerating the productivity and impact they're
having,
and you'll see that as a trend evolve
around the globe for those that invest the time
to do more with it versus just learn it,
use it. Yes, I thought one of the most
amazing things for me is
there's only 2 countries in the study that we did
that oversupply, right? So the majority
is we have not enough workers
to do the work that's needed to hit those GDP
goals that we have, except in 2 countries,
and those were Germany and those were Japan,
right? There's going to be an oversupply over the next
few years,
but, and this is really Good for everybody here
in this room.
If you look at the tech industry, it's
still something like 36%
growth skyrocketing. So you guys are in the
right spot, I guess is what I'm saying. You're in
the right industry that's going up.
OK, let's take it, um,
sort of out of the, the, the, the theory
and the economic and start to get a little bit more
applicable to the people here in the audience,
um. Ray, would you, could you
give us a little bit of insight or maybe like
your top three recommendations
at both the organization level
and probably at the individual level
on how to, how to navigate these shifts
that are,
you know, being thrown at us
uh through agentic AI.
So I, I, I'll start off with a bit of a
a summary and to paint a bit of a picture. So
if AI is the engine,
then, then learning really is the fuel.
And, and without power, without the fuel,
essentially the engine stays dormant and doesn't
get moving.
So at Pearson, we know that learning
is a lifelong
force multiplier. It compounds
just like interest does, and it's
not something you do once, it's something
that for most uh
learners, um.
At the baseline, really learning lifts
people
from poverty.
It, it, it enables people to
live healthier lives, live happier lives,
you know, when we learn, we are typically
generally happier,
and, and in the era
of AI
that that force multiplier is
really multiplying
because the, the, the truth
of the matter is in the future,
knowing how to learn.
and, and, and how to learn deep
and how to learn wide and
fast, abs, you know,
that's, that's the essence, how to go fast
and how to learn deep and how to learn continuously
is going to be the skill of
the future and that superpower that's needed.
Before AI
we, we, we used, we
used to essentially learn to earn,
so it was cyclical, you'd go to school, then you'd
go to. and then you'd earn
some money. Now
we're seeing a massive shift um
where you actually are learning to learn
and the people that are going to be able to keep at pace
and and organizations because
essentially people are organizations are
going to have to
know how to learn and how to
learn faster, how to retain and how to
stay at pace
with the growth of technology and
the growth that's happening within AI.
And at Pearson,
we have that science, that pedagogy,
we have
essentially
decades and decades of learning of
how people learn
and through our work with AWS,
through our work with ServiceNow, we're building
tools and products essentially that are embedded
in the flow of work that are
giving you that constant feedback
and really organizations
that essentially. Still look at learning
as something on the sidelines,
something that is not actually
embedded in the flow of work,
will essentially stay behind.
So really thinking about learning,
investing in learning and moving forward
with it embedded,
continuous in your in your daily
habit tools is really
something that every organization has
to has to adopt
and has to adopt very, very quickly. And
they have to do it ubiquitously across
all of the organization across
um all of their business units.
Yeah, so you, you're effectively saying that
the skill of learning is the most
important skill you can have
in this world. That's
so um and that's really great and that's some perspective
certainly from Pearson which is
focused around lifelong learning and so forth.
Let's take a little technical lens, right,
so. From a ServiceNow perspective,
can you answer the same kind of top
three recommendations for how
organizations and individuals navigate this, but
through sort of a tech lens on that?
Yes, no, of course, and at ServiceNow
we say, you know, we put AI to work
for the people, and that starts
with, you know, embracing AI and partnering
with AI in a way that it's going to
complement the thing. You're doing day to day,
embracing it in a way beyond, you know, you
learn it,
you orchestrate it, but also you're going to do
more with it in the sense of
setting goals, learning about
what means, you know, good in
terms of data that is output
and being able to really embrace
kind of an end to end approach where it's
trustworthy
and you're building on it in a way that's going to have
impact, that's valuable,
the human. Element is going to stay involved in
this too. It's not just about the tech or
the agents. So like the human element of
creativity,
application, complex thinking
needs to stay in place. And that's
why the third point is, you know, governance
is guardians. We all are that, you know, when we're
embracing AI and we're working with
data within an organization that just doesn't
fall on the C-suite or the
chief risk officer. We're all handling
that data and we need to handle it responsibly
and think about not only what we're putting in
but what's coming out and how we're applying it
and using it to make decisions
and uh you know foster the outcome
that we're looking to achieve
in terms of that balance of
innovation and capability
from learning is that combination of skill
that that the people are looking for it's gonna be
valuable as the workforce evolves.
Yeah, that's really, that's really interesting. So one
of the um.
The other things that stood out to me was
if you start to look at the demand for genic
AI skills, you, you, you can, I
mean any of the web crawlers, anybody who's looking
at that skills base
sees this incredible hockey stick
at this point.
But if you actually look and you overlay that
with governance skills,
0.
Zero increase whatsoever.
So you're seeing this agentic AI skill base
go through the moon,
and then you have a completely flat for
anything governance related to agentic AI
governance, right? So if anybody's looking for a
new job, I got a feeling at some point
they're going to have to close that gap. It might be an
interesting area to get into.
Um, OK, so that
was, you know, we've taken it down to the individual,
we've taken a look at the organization and we've looked at
the macro.
Um, Ray, how would you,
I guess, look at
how this is impacting you? So let's
make it a little bit more personal.
So from the teams and, and from Pearson's
perspective internally
within our own company,
um, could you give us a little insight on that?
Yeah, yeah, Jay, uh,
so, so I will say this, uh, you know,
at Pearson.
Um,
uh, AI has been part of our DNA,
uh, for a good 18 months now.
Um, and we're very fortunate
to essentially have,
um, leaders that, um,
are, are, are very keen on, on, on Pearson
being at the forefront,
um, of essentially driving,
uh, AI and, and, and, and,
and education through AI.
Um, and, and, and
we have, uh, every Pearson
employee has
access to AI through their daily habit tools, which
is a wonderful thing to see.
And we also have KPIs and personal
goals
to get trained and get certified on AI.
After all, we are an education
and a certification credentialing organization.
Uh, so we like to be customer zero before we
roll things out, uh, to, to,
to our customers,
um, and we also like to drink, uh, our
own champagne or eat our own dog food,
uh, depending on how you, what the saying is.
Um, and so
moving forward, what we want to do is
essentially harness
the power of AI
and work with partners
such as AWS, such as ServiceNow
to bring real customized
ways of learning, AI tutors.
Coaches that are digital in the
flow of work,
um, and we also want to be an organization
that revolutionize education and
makes sure that everybody comes along,
um, so that's a big part and AI can actually
do that and can help us do that at scale, so
a lot of things that we used to think about in
the past, and, and of course then
you've got the innovation side, you've got.
How does it impact our operations,
our customer service, HR and
finance? So we're making all those changes
and what it's doing there is it's taking
away from the,
the, you know, the mundane robotic
aspect of tasks that none of us
really like to do
and that AI is very good at,
but it also gives us and allows us
the chance to give elbow room for our
people
to essentially do the things that AI is
not good at.
Um, and that's the human side of
things, uh, and to,
uh, you know, mostly on the,
on the softer skills,
agility,
leadership, communication, that kind of thing.
And we're also hell bent moving forward
in the future on becoming an
organization that
part of that circle of organizations that's not
just investing in AI
to cost cut,
but to actually augment and enable
a human workforce
uh to to be more human and to do
those elements that I talked about before.
Thanks, Ray. Anything to add, Ryan?
Yeah, I mean, it also comes down when we're
talking about the technology side and, and what
we're doing with, uh, you know, Pierson View and
and AWS. It comes down to the, the
models, the AI, the choice that that
you have on what, um, AI
models you want to use, for example, with,
you know, the nowlysis platform on
ServiceNow and how we've built,
you know, integrations with AWS as, as,
as a hyper scaler
choice for our customers
is a great collaboration we have to make sure
that you, you have the approach and. Governance
and security you need to move forward
with your use cases.
That's great. Thank you. So I kind of
heard several things come out as in summary
points. One is learning
to learn.
That is a primary skill
that everybody needs to get comfortable with,
right? The technology is outpacing
our skills right now. So getting
comfortable with that. I can,
you know, I think my grandfather had one job
his entire life, worked for 40 years
at it. My father had a I think 2 or
3. I've had 5 on
Gen X, right? But you're starting to see that
get more and more. But now there's a new twist
to it. It's not just I'm a role,
I'm one particular role
in multiple different companies. It's
starting to blend where my role
is evolving
consistently. I can give you a little bit more insight
into what we found,
particularly against all the ecosystem roles
that are sitting in the audience right now, the
data leaks, the architects, and so forth.
In the next 5 years,
our analysis is showing about 12
to 15 hours of time
being capacity being released in your workday
due to the impact of these technologies.
So unless we're all going to a 3 day work week,
which I don't think we are anytime soon, your
job's going to evolve. They're going to combine roles. They're
going to start looking for new.
Ask, so just be ready for it. So learning to learn is
one. The second thing is around
governance, right? Everybody has to be responsible
for governance, and I guess the third is really
like, look, we're all in this together.
It's here already. This isn't you kick it
down the road a little bit. We're already in the middle of
it, so I'm excited.
I will, um, I want to give a
quick pitch. We, we,
we produced this report and it got so
much success around the world that
we've uh. Post
after that over the last 3 months we've actually
released
10 individual reports per country
so there's one for every single country.
What we're both using it. Both
Pierson and ServiceNow is using it to have
conversations with governments,
to have conversations with the institutions that
we talk with, and commercial
enterprises as well.
So this is a great way to start a conversation
about what their skilling strategy and so forth,
but to actually have data
that represents that
there's a, um, it's
a public on the ServiceNow website. So the way you can find
it, just type in workforce skills forecast
report, and it's available to anybody in this room
free of charge,
OK. We got about a little
bit of time left, but I think I'm going to excuse
everybody early. Thank you so much. It was such a pleasure.
I know your time is valuable, so thanks for
spending it with us.
Thank you so much, everyone. Thank you.